[Music]  uh this season but hopefully everybody  is now getting healthy so they can build  up those rosters and continue to get  continuity we are underway here in  brooklyn the nets won the first meeting  on christmas  122 to 115 behind a triple-double from  james harden and 31 points from paddy  mills james lopped it up oh  big finish  anthony davis to open play welcome back  to the brow  did you ask me like what anthony davis  having him back means well there you go  on the first play of the game  stanley johnson he will defend you like  a blanket frank vogel has loved what  he's brought to the squad well he has  but this is anthony davis empty the  strong side corner  and lebron  is able to occupy two or three defenders  and you throw it up for a.d welcome back